quand on a une grande différence d'âge
parfois ça passe mais pour être honnête
a parfois les chemins se séparent et
c'est normal qui a dit ça tu me regardes
non mais pas du tout lens boccolini
c'est jordan d'élus se regarder ouais
c'est ça et ça il faut être très honnête
quand on a une grande différence d'âge
parfois ça passe mais il faut être il
faut et au nom parfois il ya les chemins
ce secret ces essais et c'est normal un
foie il ya une dame qui était venu
draguer votre mec dans un restaurant
c'est vrai cette histoire mais plein de
fois je vais genre vous étiez ça
mais plein de fois parce que en fait il
y avait dans l'imaginaire de ces gens là
le fait qu'il était
qu'il était pas vraiment avec moi ou
avec moi pour les mauvaises raisons
zach duke a mal aux 25e et
malheureusement il ya tellement de
contre exemple à ce qu'elle dit je suis
désolé mais là julie gayet vient
d'épouser françois hollande par la femme
de jean marie bigard ne je pense pas
qu'elle va le quitter de sitôt enfin et
d exhaure mais l'attaquant lee je prends
l'exemple inverse au contraire on parle
plus d'une femme plus âgée c'est vrai
que c'est beaucoup plus rare et elle l'a
beaucoup dit déjà quand elles étaient
accueillies mika il ya pas de n'y a pas
de coups que tu ne vois aucun
accroc
[Applaudissements]
mais le président de la république et sa
femme sont l'exemple parfait joue ça
s'appelle une exception si ça peut
arriver encore elle croit sa propre
histoire comme meilleur gens contents
cuba c'est là c'est la vérité absolue
manon née louise monde dans le quartier
s'est pas aidé mais pour ça mon associé
tout le monde l'a fait c'est un peu
comme ça et tu te dis toujours ben moi
je connais un pote il a pas de bras pas
de jambes pape tête il a réussi à
traverser l'océan ok c'est ton pote mais
dans la grande majorité des grecs n'a
pas tout ça mais a du mal à travers
signer ces enquêtes vont tourner la
grande majorité des cas camp du non
était un exemple
la
grande majorité des cas c'est vrai
qu'une femme beaucoup plus âgés c'est
compliqué mais d'où ça sort services et
paf mais là ça privés sont aussi d'être
hypocrite on parle sur tout ça parce que
son mec et mister tahiti
quand il est tombé amoureux il ya très
longtemps elle vous fait quoi il a vu
chez moi un soir avec lui pour la
première fois et évidemment il y avait
un côté trop fait bien sûr qu'un chien
ce garçon était juste formidable plus
jeune qu'elle est que tout est à la fois
tu sentais chez laurent c'est un truc de
presque un poste d' imposture il ya un
sentiment ça m'est tombé dessus et en
vrai je mérite pas et laurent c'est une
fille super bien c'est une vraie bonne
personne ceux qui la connaissent
pourront dire s'il y avait un côté très
touchant
poisse a pas été simple
dans l'interview après qu'est hyper
intéressant elle dit justement qui se
faisait souvent drague et parfois même
devant elle
d'accord elle a rajouté aussi un truc
très important c'est qu'aujourd'hui elle
veut refaire sa vie elle est célibataire
elle veut quelqu'un mais elle fera ce
choix aussi en fonction de sa fille
pascale à une petite fille willow et que
du coup elle va vraiment voilà les pas
sur le marché comme elles pouvaient
l'être il ya quinze ou vingt ans